Audubillahi mina Shaytana regime, Bismillahir Rahmanir Rahim, Allahumma Salliya Allah Sayyidina Muhammadin, Waala Ali Sayyidina Muhammadin, Kamas Allaytawa Salam Tawa Baraktawa Rahim Tawa Tarahamta Ala Ibrahim, Waala Ali Ibrahim, Fila Alamina Inna Kahamidu Majid, Rabbish Rahli Sadri, Wa Yasir Li Amri, Wahlul Uqdata mill Lisani, Yaf Kahu Kawli, Salaam Alaikum wa Rahmatullahi wa Barakatu
So in the previous session, we learned that Maliki Omid Deen, it linguistically what it means is the owner, Malik or Malik, which is king.
So the owner or the king of the time period when the debt of submission falls due.
And we talked about the imperfections of this world which necessitate
this idea of a perfect world which is the hereafter.
Today we look at this verse in some more detail and I want to help us understand its purpose and its relevance in the surah especially from the point of view of this transition that we see taking place here.
So
If you look at the theme of the Surah so far, we saw that from the beginning, Allah's love and His mercy was being highlighted, right?
I begin with the lofty symbols of Allah that are pointing to His immense love and mercy.
All sincere praise and all unconditional gratitude is due to Allah for His mastery
His lordship over this 'alam which is everything that can be known in existence.
So, Alhamdulillahi Rabbila alameen, the abundantly merciful, the consistently merciful.
So, if you look at this, right, Allah's love is being highlighted in the surah and now suddenly there is this switch that we see in tone and Allah changes his tone to say, Maliki Aumiddin
owner of the time when the debt of submission falls due right why this sudden change in tone so scholars explain that this transition is extremely profound and its purpose is to engender this desire for taqwa in our hearts so it is what the Arabs called al-bais
which is what basically stimulates you to do something, something that motivates you.
It's the motivating factor about something.
Because if you think about it, if love is not balanced with some system of accountability, it is human tendency to start taking advantage of that kindness.
We see this all the time in our life.
If you know anyone in your life who is just
love, love, love all the time, someone who will let people get away with murder, what you'll see is that as much as this person might be loved, they will never be taken seriously.
In fact, they will be taken advantage of.
Isn't that the case?
So understanding this weakness in human nature
Allah changes His tone to remind us that look, even though I am a very merciful and a very loving God, but you have to take Me seriously.
Don't think you can take undue advantage of My love, because I am also your creator, I am also your owner, I am also your king and I have set a time period where I will take you to account for your debt of submission because
Nothing is happening right now to you in this world.
You are free to do whatever you want, right?
If you commit a sin right now in this world, lightning is not going to strike you down.
So what that freedom allows human nature to do is that it allows us to become heedless and this verse is basically reminding us not to be heedless.
It creates a sense of accountability and it also creates a sense of urgency
to make the most of whatever time we have remaining.
Because no one knows when and where he's going to die, right?
Except that we all know that we are going to inevitably die someday.
Wa maa tadhiri nafsun mada tak zibu gadan wa maa tadhiri nafsun bi ayi ardan tamut No soul knows what he will earn tomorrow, and no soul knows in which land it will die.
So this concept of an inevitable death and this idea of returning back to the creator for accountability, what it does is that it creates this awareness of Allah in our hearts, which is called taqwa.
This word taqwa, it comes from wirqaya, which means a strong sense of fearful awareness.
So, Taqwa is the awareness of Allah's constant presence in our lives.
So, scholars have stated that what this verse Maliki Aumiddin does is that it motivates us towards Taqwa in a number of ways.
So, today I want to go over some of those motivating factors that have been outlined by scholars.
The first they say is the fear of punishment in this world.
This is a worldly type of retribution which is called Iqab.
So human nature is such that we just naturally tend to fear pain.
In fact, fear of pain is probably a greater immediate concern than the desire for pleasure.
There were these studies done that when given two choices and the possibility of one over the other were equal, people chose to avoid pain rather than acquiring pleasure.
So the avoidance of pain, the fear of pain actually supersedes the desire for pleasure.
And so what this fear allows us to do is that it
It enables us to delay our gratification.
They did a study in the US which was I think a 30 year study.
It was very interesting.
What they did is that they took these five year old kids and they offered them a cookie.
And they said that you can have this cookie right now or if you wait 10 minutes you can have two cookies.
And so the children were very different in their choices.
And what these people did is that they monitored these kids over a 30 year period.
And what they found almost consistently was that the children that delayed their gratification for a greater reward, the children that took one cookie and waited, that left that one cookie and waited 10 minutes to get the two cookies,
basically delaying their gratification, they found that these kids were far more successful in their lives than the ones who wanted it and took it immediately.
It was a very interesting study.
So the delay of gratification, right, this temporary deprivation for the hope of something greater is very important.
And this delay is the basis of a lot of what is going on in the Quran.
this this idea of delaying gratification because the people of this Dunya they desire instant gratification right no you love this the instant gratification the present life of this world and you keep delaying you keep leaving the Hereafter so basically you put off what's coming
And you just want this immediate pleasure.
And this is something we all are guilty of.
We all fall into lust.
It's an immediate pleasure.
It's instant gratification.
It's an immediate satisfaction.
And we often end up sacrificing doing the right thing to gain this immediate pleasure.
And we don't think of repercussions.
But that's the way we are, that's just human nature.
So Maliki yawmideen is essentially what the scholars say, you know, it is the fear of punishment in the next world.
One of the things about the Islamic and essentially all Abrahamic faiths is that there's an idea that just as you have physics, you also have metaphysics.
So physics are laws that we can discern from this palpable world, right?
This world, this sensory world that we can touch and feel, it has certain laws.
And these are the laws of cause and effects.
If you do something in this world, so every action has to have a reaction.
So for instance, if I hit this table, there's going to be the sound, right?
If there was no sound, then there's a suspension of a physical law and we'd have to look into it.
Like why did that happen?
Why was there no sound?
Because according to the laws of physics, my striking this table should produce a sound.
So there are these laws of, if you jump off a building, there's going to be an effect from that cause.
Right?
So just as there are physical laws, there are also metaphysical laws.
There are laws of cause and effect that transcend the physical world.
And they move into the spiritual world or the psychic world.
So for instance, if I shout at you, if I scream at you, there is going to be a psychic effect.
It's going to have an emotional effect.
Where are emotions?
We don't truly understand where emotions lie, except that we just know that they're part of our consciousness.
But if I shout at you, you will feel something inside.
You will either feel depressed or you will become angry.
And that's coming from another realm, right?
It's not from the physical realm.
That's from the realm of emotions.
So just as there are physical effects, there are also spiritual effects, there are also psychic effects.
So for instance, the Arabs, they have this term, what they call which literally means water of the face.
But the idea is that it's a kind of purity or a kind of impurity that people have on their face.
You'll see this, people who have sinned a lot in their lives, their evil begins to show up on their faces and you get a type of metaphysical darkness in their face.
In the same way people that do a lot of good deeds, you'll see that their faces are affected by that.
They have a kind face.
You see this luminance or this brightness radiating from their face.
And this is why the Arabs used to call a face, they would call it as-Sahifa, which means the register, because it registers everything.
Somebody once said that by 50, everybody has the face that they deserve.
So if you're 50 years old, you have the face that you deserve.
If you've had a good life, it's going to show up on your face.
So that fear of another worldly punishment is one of the things that will compel a person to do good and stay within boundaries within this world by delaying gratifications.
The next motivating factor for Taqwa
is desiring a benefit.
That's the next one.
So just as people fear punishment, they also desire benefit.
This is at the most basic human foundation, right?
Stick and carrot.
This is how children are disciplined, stick and carrot.
It's how societies work, stick and carrot.
So really much of society is based on these principles.
And that's why the highest people, the elite, the most intelligent people are the ones that actually transcend these stick and carrot factors and they move into another realm.
People like Maulana Ali who often said in his prayers, Ya ilahi, ma abat tuka bishaw ka jannatika, walam in khaufin naarika, bal wajat tu mustahaqqan lia ibada fal abat tuka.
my master I do not worship you out of a desire for your paradise nor do I worship you out of fear of your hellfire instead I truly found you worthy of my worship and for that reason alone I worship you and this is a very high station of worship that completely transcends this skeleton stick philosophy it's the ideal form of worship
But the majority of people are at this base level and because the Quran speaks to all of humanity, it talks in this general manner.
There's a Hadith in which the Prophet said, move according to the level of the least amongst you.
Move according to the level of the least amongst you.
Subhanallah.
So you have to move with the least amongst you.
You don't speed up and leave people behind.
Right?
No, that's not the way of Islam.
And this is why if you carefully study this religion, you'll see that most of it is designed to protect the weakest people.
Right?
Because there are people who can stand on their own and they don't have a problem with that, but then there are also people that cannot do that and they have their human weaknesses.
And so the Sharia
It protects those people by preventing them from certain things.
And this is why the Quran speaks against things like gambling, for instance, right?
The Quran says that there is good in gambling, actually, it does say that.
Yes, aloo na ka anil khamri wal maisiri, pull feehima isthmun kabirun wa manfa'ulin naas wa isthmuha akbarum minan na fa'ihima
they ask you concerning alcohol and gambling tell them in them is a great sin and also a benefit for mankind but the sin is far greater than their benefit so Quran actually says that there is some good in gambling I mean there are lessons to be learned in gambling right risk is an interesting phenomenon in commerce
There's a strong relationship between gambling and commerce.
But the harms of gambling are far greater than its benefits.
And it is a known social science, this fact that around 3% of people that go into gambling casinos, they become addicted and it destroys their lives.
And this is why if you've ever been to a gambling casino, I mean, I've been here inside this casino at Atlantic City many years ago,
And it was one of the most frightening things I ever saw.
It was like a circle out of Dante's Inferno.
And you just see all of these people in this zombie-like state, just sitting on their seats, putting in quarters into the machine one after the other and pulling this lever.
I mean, it's a scary sight.
And then there was this pawn shop in the middle of that casino with this big sign outside that said, We take wedding rings.
That is just so sinister.
What kind of people are these?
How do you justify a job like this just depriving people in this manner, just taking advantage of human weakness?
But that's the reality of our world.
Right?
And gambling is based on the carrot phenomenon.
It's a carrot phenomenon.
You know, gamblers think that if I put in money and I pull the lever, and it's all designed so that winning will happen enough times to keep you there, right?
That's part of the design.
So when people leave, they say, oh, you know, I made such and such.
They never actually think about how much they lost.
They'll always tell you how much they won.
So that's the phenomenon of the carrot, you know, and it's used a lot and that's one of the worst things about it.
But then obviously from the worldly things, you know, these things that are pleasurable that we find in the slide, that give you instant pleasure, they're always followed by a far greater pain because that's just the design of it, isn't that?
I mean in our case, we all can give examples of that.
And this is why the Prophet he said, Paradise was surrounded by distasteful things and fire was surrounded by delightful things, pleasurable things.
So if you're walking towards paradise, you will inevitably encounter distasteful things.
It's just part of the design.
And so now it's up to the Aqil, this person of intellect, to recognize this and that's why the Quran frequently talks about Tadabur, which means to reflect deeply upon something.
You know, Quran frequently asks us ...
Why don't you reflect deeply?
It actually uses the word Tadabur a lot, which is deep reflection.
The word Tadabur comes from a root
which means to take something to its end.
Dubur is the behind of something.
It's the end of something.
Adbar is what's behind you.
So Tadabur is going through something until you get to its very end.
So that's why when you have Tadabur as a quality, you just look down the road.
Right?
You think about the consequences.
You think about where this action will end up.
Whereas this person who's just stuck in this Ajala, this haste of instant gratification, doesn't really just go beyond the present and they're just stuck right there and they don't think about the future.
And there's this interesting theory in theology about this divine experience versus a demonic experience.
And the way you differentiate between a true divine experience and a true demonic experience is that a demonic experience is always accompanied with an expansion of the self.
In other words, it is very exciting and it's a very joyful experience, the demonic experience.
But then it is always followed with despair.
On the contrary, a true spiritual experience, a true divine experience is exactly the opposite.
The initial experience is incredible constriction and it's incredible fear and dread, but then it is followed by a sense of expansion and joy.
So, you know, anyway, so the benefit, acquiring a benefit is the second motivating factor for Taqla.
The next motivating factor, scholars say, and benefits of this verse, Malik-i-Aumidin, the other benefit that it provides is that it gives us the grounds for the fear of a reckoning.
That you're going to be reckoned on the day of judgment.
And so this fear of reckoning, it should instill
in our hearts this desire to do good.
You see, anyone who has a business, they have what they call internal audits.
If you have a business and you live in a country like the US or England, for instance, where they have these revenue services, these are external agencies that will come in and they will examine your books, they will examine your business.
And if you've been fudging the books, then you'll get penalties.
It's not just that you will pay what you owe in back taxes and things like that.
They will actually add penalties and they will add interest and they will do all these kinds of things.
So companies that are worried about that external reckoning or that external auditing by the revenue
services what they do is that they conduct an internal audit and so if there's anything that needs correcting they will correct it internally and that's what's called in our terms it's called Mahasiva and it's part of Taqwa where you actually take your own self to account
The hadith says Take yourself to account before you are taken to account.
And this is why it has been said that when a true believer, when he lies down to sleep at night, he reflects on his actions for the day.
And the things that he found that he did wrong, he asks Allah for forgiveness and he
makes a determination to correct those things in the next day.
So this is why this concept of Muhasiba is an extremely important concept within Islam.
The next benefit of this verse is that it creates this concept of shame or modesty from the awareness of God.
That Allah is aware of our actions, that Allah is watching us.
So we should have this shame or this modesty before Allah Haya The word Al-Haya in Arabic is probably better translated as modesty which is related to shame There's a sense that you don't want to do something in front of a person or in front of your Lord out of love and respect There are certain things that children won't do in front of their parents out of respect
The Prophet , he said: Every religion has a peculiar characteristic and the characteristic of my religion is modesty.
Anthropologists, they divide cultures into two types of cultures.
They divide it as shame based cultures and then guilt based cultures.
So Western cultures generally tend to fall into the guilt culture.
And a guilt culture, it cultivates within people moral components inside of themselves where
If they do something wrong, they feel bad about it on the inside.
And so one of the things a lot of people know about people in the West is that they will often find it very difficult to do wrong things without actually feeling bad.
In fact, there's a whole industry in America to help people overcome this
feeling of guilt, self-help books, self-improvement courses.
There's a whole industry that capitalizes on this idea of helping people overcome guilt.
So in guilt cultures, there's an internal mechanism.
In shame-based cultures, the mechanisms are external.
And so people, they don't do wrong things out of fear of others.
They don't do wrong things out of fear of others.
which generally creates hypocrisy in cultures.
And India and Pakistan and many Asian countries are very much rooted in the shame based culture where people don't have an internal component and they're only controlled from external factors.
So when such a person is in his own country, in his own community, he finds it shameful to do certain things, but when he goes to another country,
where nobody knows him it's no longer shameful to do those same things right they start doing them and and they don't really feel any guilt inside or any shame inside and this is why you know a lot of kids from India and Pakistan when they come to the US for studies or things like that or you know any other Western country they go completely crazy they start drinking they start partying they do drugs and even though they never did those things when they were back home
It just becomes completely acceptable overnight because they're no longer in the culture where to do those things was shameful.
And also, a different country or a different city, it provides anonymity, right?
When people move into different countries, into different environments, because back home, everybody knows you, right?
They know your parents.
So if you do anything, the entire community is going to hear about it.
The entire Jamaat is going to hear about it.
In a different city or a different country, there is this anonymity.
So it's difficult to sense that shame, which is why guilt cultures are very important in advanced societies and shame, it works very well at the tribal level, right?
It works quite well in small cultures, but when you move to advanced cultures like the West, it breaks down.
now Islam is rooted in a shame based culture but what it does is that it transcends the shame that is rooted in people and it grounds it in shame before God so it's not so much of an internal factor it is still an external factor right meaning it's more shame based
but it has to do with this modesty, this Haya before God, before the prophet, before the angels, right?
Because you have these two angels on each side recording everything that we do.
So the idea is that you become aware of the spiritual presence
that then prevents you from doing wrong things and this is called which is a very high station it is a station of vigilance or this constant awareness of Allah's presence based on his word in the Quran indeed Allah sees everything and is aware of everything
The use of this term is so beautiful.
Raqib.
Raqib is the jealous lover.
You know, like if you're in love with someone and that person is in love with another person, so that other person becomes your Raqib, right?
And it is the nature of a Raqib that you're constantly gonna spy on them, constantly be aware of every move they make, right?
That's a Raqib.
the jealous lovers.
Allah says that Allah is watching you like a jealous lover.
He's watching every single move of it.
The metaphors, the analogies are so beautiful in the Quran.
So there is this idea of shame.
There's this very interesting story over a hundred years ago when British ruled India, they say they lived a pickpocket, right?
He was a Muslim, but his job was just picking pockets of people.
He was a thief.
In fact, he was a member of a gang who did this.
There was an entire gang dedicated to just, they would go out and then they would pick pockets all day and then bring all the earnings in the night.
So one day, this man, he picked the pocket of an Englishman, of a Britisher, and that wallet had a lot of money in it.
So he was quite happy initially.
But then he thought of something and then he went and returned that wallet back to that Englishman.
And that night when he returned back to his gang, the leader would ask everyone how much did they earn that day.
And so when his turn came, he said, you know, I did pick the pocket of this rich English man, this Christian, but then I decided to return it back.
And when asked why, he said,
You know, I thought that on the Day of Judgment, if Christ came to Rasulullah and said, A man of your nation picked the pocket of a man from my nation, my Prophet would have to feel shame before him on my account.
And I just cannot be the reason to put my Prophet to shame before Christ.
And so I returned his wallet to him.
right and I mean this was the level of awareness of just people a hundred years ago because they were concerned about putting the putting our Prophet to shame and in his last sermon to his nation Rasulullah SAW in his last Khutbah one of the things he said was .............................................
put me to shame on the Day of Judgment.
You know, when a classroom produces a bad result, the teacher feels shame, right?
Isn't he asked, What's the matter?
Why did so many children fail in your class today?
And our Prophet, his last request to us was, My people do not shame me before Allah on the Day of Judgment.
There is this verse in Urdu poetry, which I love so much.
It's wojo geet tum neso na nahi, mere umre bhar kari astha.
Mere dard ki tivo das tanjis at tum haseema ragai.
so there's the story about I don't know if this story is true or not but nevertheless it demonstrates this beautiful love that this man had for his prophet and it was grounded in shame because he felt ashamed at the idea of being the reason for the prophet's shame so it was still an external factor but it transcended the realm of people and it was rooted in a higher dimension and may Allah give us all this awareness of
understanding that just having this awareness of being not just being ashamed before the Prophet but also putting the Prophet to shame before Allah based on our you know this man who strived 23 years of his life for us and we cannot even produce the most basic result for him the next motivating factor for Taqwa is
gratitude over the blessing of Allah for all the blessings of Allah by being obedient.
So the next thing that Maliki Ahmadine this verse helps us with is obtaining taqwa through the recognition of Allah's blessings and demonstrating the gratitude for those blessings through obedience.
So it's this awareness that every blessing that you have, Allah gave it to you.
If God gave you sight, the gratitude for that sight is to use it for the sake of Allah.
If He gave you hearing, the gratitude for hearing is to use it for the sake of Allah.
If He gave you physical strength, everything should be used for what it was made for.
So Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala He did not create
His creation and desire disobedience from them.
He enables disobedience which is called khizlaan.
So Allah is the enabler.
He allows disobedience to happen but He's not content with it.
He does not want His servants to be in a state of ingratitude even though He allows it.
So it's very important to have gratitude for the blessings by using those blessings in obedience.
That is the definition of shukr.
To use the gifts that Allah has given you to perform things that are pleasing to Allah .
The next motivating factor is knowledge.
So knowledge actually provides a reason to have Taqla.
Now if you notice, there is this ascension that is taking place in the motivations here.
We started off with the base levels, which is the fear of punishment and the desire for a reward.
Then it transcended, it went higher into this idea of a reckoning and then just gratitude through obedience and now a higher realm of knowledge, which is the next motivating factor for Taqla.
which is based on Il right because Allah says Indeed the ones who are truly fearful of Allah who have Khushur they are the scholars the word Khushur is a type of Taqwa that comes from a fearful awareness of God through knowledge it comes from awe before God
that is based on knowledge of who Allah is.
And it is amongst His creation, amongst His servants, it is the Ulama that have this knowledge.
And then the magnification of Allah's majesty, right?
And this is called Maqam al-Hayba, which is the station of awe.
and which is a higher station than, you know, just even just basic gratitude.
Because it comes from this awe that is produced by the knowledge of who Allah is, right?
It's called maqam al-haiba.
The mohib is someone who has this awe for a greater, like for the Sultan, right?
There's an awe that goes with it.
so you know when you go visit a Sultan there's a whole way that they have made things in order to instill this awe in your hearts for him so for instance if you go to the White House to meet the president you'll see these marine guards with guns standing outside that have these big bayonets I mean there's a reason why the bayonets are there I mean they could have just had the guns right why do you need those bayonets
But the bayonet is there to instill this haiba, right?
Bayonet is this little sword-like thing, this knife-like thing that is attached to the gun, to the barrel of the gun.
Why do they need that?
In case of an event, they'll probably shoot rather than stab, but why is there that knife?
Because it's meant to instill this haiba in our hearts.
It's the same with just swords outside the palace of a king in Arabia.
It creates Haiba.
And then you go in and then there are all these long corridors made of marble and this expensive stuff and they make you walk through all of these magnificent corridors with all of these elegant decorations.
Why?
The purpose is to humble you because you're about to meet the Sultan, you're about to meet the President, the Prime Minister, the King.
And so this whole experience that they make you go through is to produce this kind of humility within your heart to put you in your place, you see?
And no matter where you go, they all have the same type of rituals.
Whether you go to the Queen's palace or you go to the White House or to go to the Sultan's palace, they're all designed to create this awe in your heart for the Sultan, which is important.
Because if the Sultan does not generate this awe, then why should people obey him in the first place?
And this is also why traditionally Ulama dressed a certain way.
This is why RasulAllah encouraged Ulama to dress in this certain particular way so that it instills this awe, this respect in the hearts of the audience.
Otherwise, why is anybody going to listen to them?
This is why we find the Kiswa on the Kaaba, that black cloth, because it's a sanctified place, right?
That Kiswa, it illustrates the magnificence of the Kaaba.
It creates this all within our hearts.
So it's a very important aspect of Taazim.
And then the final stage, you know, is Sit-ul-Muhabba, the sincerity in one's love for God.
Right?
It gives this ultimate form of taqwa which is the highest motivating factor for taqwa.
And this is, you know, one of the poets, Mahmud al-Warraq, he said, You disobey Allah but then you claim that you love Him?
This is impossible and a very strange type of logic that I don't understand.
had your love been sincere you would have been obedient because a lover always obeys his or her beloved so the nature of love is that you want to obey the one that you love then he says
a woman asked about the state of the one who was in this burning passion for her right the ash is the one who who is in this burning passion for the beloved so she's asking this man about her lover and she says so for the sake of God
Tell me about his state.
And don't stint in your description and don't exaggerate.
In other words, I want to hear the truth.
So she asks this man, tell me about his love.
Tell me what kind of love does he have for me.
And so this man says, If this man knew that he would die from thirst,
And if you said don't touch that water, he wouldn't touch it.
So if your lover is gonna die of thirst and you said don't touch that drink of water, he won't touch it.
He'd rather die than disobey you.
So the point of that, what the poet is emphasizing is that it is the nature, obedience is the nature of love.
The very nature of love is to be obedient.
So the more you love God, the more you will obey God.
And that's the idea.
And so the Ulama has stated these, think of it like a
staircase, right?
And think of all of these motivating factors as rungs.
So it begins with the fear of punishment, then the next step is deciding the rewards, then it is having this concept of reckoning, this accountability before God, right?
And then shame, the next level is having shame before God, his prophet and his angels.
then the next level is gratitude, then the next is knowledge, and finally you reach the final stage of love, which is sincere love manifested through obedience.
So it's a very, you know, it's a very beautiful and a very powerful verse, Maliki yumiddin, and its purpose is to motivate us towards Taqwa.
And so you have, you know, with Alhamdulillahi Rabbil Alameen, Ar-Rahman Ar-Raheem, Maliki Aumiddin, from these three verses, we get a complete picture of who Allah is.
Right?
So it provides a complete description, a very concise description of who Allah is.
The next, the following verses that we will study in future sessions
so these next verses they give us an understanding of what Allah wants from us and what we want from Allah and so this is how the Surah Fateha is split into these two parts you have the first these beginning three verses which tells us in third person who Allah is
And then, ...
from there, it begins this transition of what we are asking Allah for.
So, inshAllah, we'll explore those verses in the following sessions, inshAllah.
Wa akharuda'wanan alhamdulillahi rabbil alameen wassalatu wassalamu ala rasulihi saydana muhammadin khatim nabiyin was sayid al-mursaleen wa ala akhihi wa wassiyaalid nabi taliba shrafil wassayeen wa alal ayimatiman zuriatima tayibina tahirin wassalam alaihi majma'in al-Fateha